[Music]
[Applause]
the season premiere advance eager to
start the competition was on in the
ballroom Monday night ET is running down
the season 24 premieres biggest
standouts surprises and slip-ups Glee
star Heather Morris impressed alongside
her partner Maksim Chmerkovskiy
so did fifth Harmony's normani Corday
with Max's brother Val NFL Pro Rashad
Jennings with Emma Slater and Olympic
gold medalist Simone biles who earned
the highest score of the night 32 with
her Pro Sascha Farber I think it went
pretty well I mean I'm very proud of me
bachelor Nick vial proved he's got
skills on the dance floor the 36 year
olds cha-cha with Peta Murgatroyd
delivered
[Applause]
I just try to be in the moment it was
the great energy it was amazing it was
so much fun
ice-skating Pro Nancy Kerrigan dazzled
two decades after winning big at the
Olympics and bull rider boner Bolton's
instant chemistry with partner Sharna
Burgess was hot hot hot so hot it got
the internet buzzing after this awkward
moment I was looking at the TV screen
Chris Kattan paid tribute to his
memorable role in a night at the Roxbury
[Music]
but his moves fell a bit short he and
Witney Carson were at the bottom of the
leaderboard with 17 out of 40 right
above them mr. t and Kim Johnson who
earned a 20 out of 40 you can fall but
you get back up you know like a I had
put out a tweet I said and I wasn't
joking I said I might fall I might slip
I might miss a beat but I won't quit and
that's what it's all about
we did we did we won't quit
[Music]
you